AINSLEY: NEW MASSIVE ORGANIZED
CARAVAN OF PARENTS STORMING
THROUGH A BLOCKADE OF MEXICO CAB
SECURITY FORCES, LOOK AT THAT AS
THEY MAKE THEIR WAY NORTH
TOWARDS THE UNITED STATES.
THOMAS FEELEY IS A FORMER ICE
OFFICE DIRECTOR FOR BUFFALO, NEW
YORK AND JOINS US NOW TO REACT.
GOOD MORNING, THOMAS.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY, HOW
ARE YOU?
AINSLEY: DOING WELL.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE YOU, DOES
IT?
WE DON'T EXPECT HIM TO FOLLOW
THE LAW.
>> NO IT DOESN'T, AS LONG AS THE
DOOR REMAINS OPEN, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO COME AND WHAT'S
REALLY SHOCKING ABOUT THIS
CARAVAN IS THEY ARE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATING THAT OBEY THE LAWS
OF WHEREBY THEY ARE CURRENTLY
AT.
THERE IS NO EXPECTATION THAT
THEY WILL OBEY OUR LAWS HAD WHEN
THEY GET HERE.
AINSLEY: WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY
GET HERE?
>> ONLY RESPONSE I'M AWARE OF BY
DHS IS TO DETAIL PEOPLE FROM THE
BORDER FROM ISIS DDBP THEY ARE
NOT THERE TO STOP IT OR CLOSE
THE BORDER OR DO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION.
THEY ARE ONLY THERE TO HELP
PROCESS THESE PEOPLE AND GET
THEM INTO THE COUNTRY QUICKER.
SO, I DON'T KNOW WHAT DHS IS
DOING.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE OUR VICE
PRESIDENT WHERE THE IS THE IS,
OPEN BORDER IS WHAT THEY WANTED
OPEN BORDER IS WHAT THEY GOT.
AINSLEY: SAYING APPLICATIONS NOT
BEING PROCESSED AND FULL HEADING
TO MEXICO CITY.
BEING TOLD 4,000 OF THEM.
DO YOU EXPECT THEM?
CARRYING AMERICAN FLAGS, WEARING
BIDEN T-SHIRTS AND HOLDING UP
BIDEN SIGNS, THEY'RE HEADING FOR
THE U.S., AREN'T THEY?
>> YEAH.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IF ANY OF
THEM THERE WEAR LET'S GO BRANDON
SHIRTS BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
REALLY FUNNY.
THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP COMING AS
LONG AS THE BORDER REMAINS OPEN
AND REMAINS UNSAFE TO ALL OF US
HERE IN THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
GOING TO KEEP COMING AND KEEP
COMING AND KEEP COMING.
AINSLEY: WHERE IS THE
LEADERSHIP?
WE ARE NOT SEEING KAMALA HARRIS
GO DOWN THERE ANYMORE.
JOE BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN DOWN
THERE.
WHAT ABOUT THE HEAD OF ICE OR
DBP?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THEM?
>> WELL, THEY ARE BOTH
UNQUALIFIED FOR THEIR POSITIONS
IN MY OPINION.
BOTH CHIEFS OF POLICE WHICH AS
"HARDBALL" AS THAT IS THAT DOES
NOT PREPARE YOU TO LEAD ONE OF
THE LARGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY NOTICE COUNTRY.
BOTH OF THEM HAVE BACKGROUND IN
BEING ANTI-ICE AND PRO-OPEN
BORDERS.
SO THIS IS JUST A TRAGEDY THAT'S
GOING TO KEEP PLAYING OUT.
AND THIS IS BY DESIGN.
THIS IS WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
WANTS.
AND, YOU KNOW, AS FAR AS A LACK
OF LEADERSHIP, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
ARE ASKING WHY AREN'T AT THE
BORDER THIS IS GOING EXACTLY AS
PLANNED BY THEM ANY REACH TO GO
DOWN THERE.
SAD MORALE IS LOW.
AINSLEY: MANY PEOPLE SAY WE NEED
KAMALA HARRIS TO STAY HERE AND
DEAL WITH WHAT IS HAPPENING ON
THE BORDER.
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT THIS IS
WHAT SHE WANTS.
ALL BY DESIGN.
DOESN'T HAVE A NEED TO GO TO THE
BORDER.
SHE IS NOT GOING TO GO DOWN
THERE AND RALLY AGAINST HER OWN
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES.
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANTED.
AND, YOU KNOW, NOW SHE IS GOING
TO GO OVER TO FRANCE, I BELIEVE.
MAYBE HAVE TEA AND CRUMPETS IN
ENGLAND STOP OVER AND SAY HI TO
EVERYBODY OVER THERE THIS I